within this Square I can fit these five
cookies and if I want to be a little bit
naughty I can watch this if I sneak a
cookie and eat it I'm in trouble right
because there's missing space the
cookies don't fill the square anymore or
do they if I turn each of the remaining
cookies 180 degrees they fill the square
again it's not magic it's math and
psychology and I want you to do it at
home that is why we made this a silicone
baking mold that you can put dough in
and then bake into cookies to perform
the illusion the cookies pop right out
of the silicone and it's wonderful the
kit also comes with a silicone baking
mat and a unique little spatula with ink
on it
this is just one of the several pieces
of delicious brain food we cooked up and
put in the latest curiosity box join at
curiositybox.com and use code illusion
to save twenty dollars